[Music]
and I see dead people new Oh
I never want to see them I do submitted
by baklava drama I know best a big drama
my office yep I had to almost party my
crazy they make you fart those ones did
well I don't know why it's the Spanish
baklava Airport bacalao because that's a
very reason extreme look all box of us
have you had that since that you're
allergic are nothing apart yeah well a
man recently shared to Twitter a
terrifying tale of a ghost who wants to
kill him about that I'll step outside
let me know when you guys are finished
so this man his name is Adam this is all
on Twitter so he starts August Twitter
thread with it so my apartment is
currently being haunted by the ghost of
a dead child and he's trying to tell me
that's cure in disease thread children
don't want to kill thanks to Twitter but
if it's a child ghost the ones that show
up with their hair covering the face
they do want to tell you thank you Greg
it's just a demon pretending to be a
child room yep Oh child red with the
wooden space so next week he started
appearing in dream but I think he's
crossed over into the real world man oh
my gosh the first time I saw him I was
experiencing sleep paralysis and saw a
child sitting in the green rocking chair
at the foot of my bed you see why the
[ __ ] I don't want a rocking chair yeah I
remember service yep because he wanted
to get a rocking chair so when I'm I
didn't want to get one well because you
want to hold on to finish you could get
one he's like hey why don't we make it
convenient for you to nurse and we can
put a rocking chairs big bass note a
little bit I want you up on any shot I
want to get across here then you wanted
to get a rocking chair massage chair for
her nursing yeah how I can use it was
you done that's kind of nice is it the
whole body's vibrating with the babies
of
I don't want it to start anymore
continue I want to hear now I want to
hear all I guess what he wanted so we
had that conversation it was a kind
gesture he's like oh why don't we just
get a rocking chair I mean I said are
you [ __ ] kidding me have you not seen
[ __ ] scary movies
it took a magnet Leo's right it's such
an old piece of furniture nobody like Oh
whatever good news were you rocking -
that's a collider you have a gliding one
I'm down with the glider not a [ __ ]
rocking chair that's a postman my gun
next to my [ __ ] bedside I've seen a
lot of movies last mouthful - rocking
chair and some [ __ ] pieces cool but
the ghost is still there no the ghost is
dead you don't make it died with the
rocking chair yes okay so I said ghost
dies again you never saw that movie with
my gun it does the ghost size again do
you all you need is a mirror with
Chinese lettering instant a month to
come over to bless the whole place
sage holy water cross sobbing coat
handle by the door Charlotte yeah
garlic for the vampire holy water I'm
silver bullets
every Bible arrow ever possibly exist
some ginger and onion a judoka for
changeful and you're good yep I do kit
yeah telling them on kicker I'm dried
noose always got to have dried newts in
case they smell like salamanders I put
in a cauldron I don't have time to shop
for all this [ __ ] and Amazon probably
doesn't have all that guaranteed or do
they add new time now you can well I'm
not getting a [ __ ] rock because of
this Barry - look what if someone gifts
it to you then I'm gifting that [ __ ]
back I'm hit I love the gesture keep
your [ __ ] goes on you need a
hydraulic chair for your rule I'm down
does the volume is not a rocking chair
oh my god okay Joe a lot of hydraulic
chair don't be sorry so your face is
dirty trying all right
hey he had a huge misshapen head and was
dented on one side I did my best to
drive this is what he drew
oh that looks like what's up I'm your
great artist ed ed many it was like the
guy with the wood oh yeah ed no no yeah
one that had 31 that was another right
ah I don't think his brain was plagued a
plane but I can't remember what his name
was already looks like do you remember
that movie the one with the Tom Hanks
and sixth senses no no that was no good
I think there's no bruce moy man and a
baby we were ghosts in the shot no yeah
that one creeped me out were like he's
like actually dead spoiler alert but
like he doesn't know that he's dead
thank you not that Bruce Willis Bruce
Willis ha ha ha
oh wait I wasn't even in that dream in
in a baby oh my god me very well for a
while you just stared at me but then he
got out of the chair and started
trembling towards the bed what does that
mean
I don't know probably maybe like oh no
metric hose as I know to Shambu or Mego
just like yeah generally is probably all
distorted like we probably look like The
Grudge yeah look Joe you're way too good
at that now you look like you're dead
[Laughter]
I couldn't move because I was paralyzed
parenthesis I had sleep paralysis fairly
often everyone does what the [ __ ] I hate
that I've never had sleep paralysis oh
well you will now that you said that and
scary I got a black shadow lingering on
top of my body I had one word the
feeling was like somebody was crawling
up on me I'm like coming by blowing wind
in my ear and it's like did you like a
fan on their club like that I did have a
banner or anything so creepy see I feel
like that stuff is like sleeping oh this
feels like it's like kind of opening a
different dimension well you know what
it really is all right you'll be wide
open no no what so what happens if your
brain goes into a REM cycle and when you
have sleep paralysis I forgot which
parvis some part of you wakes up at the
other party still asleep so that's where
you can't
move and then we see things is because
you're it's your dream that you're in
the real world so eyes are always
negative my sus care yeah like what
could it be like like my mom saying wake
up I made you some breakfast oh yeah I
can't get up you know like it's always
some kind of like oh yeah because when
you're in your REM cycle your body
completely like shuts yeah you love dial
pretty Wiggly oh yeah beeping and then
so when you wake up your body's still
thinking that is asleep sighs so are
your eyes actually open yeah you can see
yeah yeah your eyes open Wow I don't
know I feel like you actually see you
see your dream no that's the scientific
explanation but the realistic one is
that which is way more important in
science right is the see that's the
physical explanation right like this is
REM whatever whatever but in reality
you're still stuck in the dream world
portal where you're communicating with
the other beings and then you're kind of
halfway and halfway out so that when
you're like open your eyes right the
thing that I don't understand is why is
it always got to be scary and negative I
never had that darkness always brings in
negative spirits and energy like that's
why they always say when you're scared
you keep a light on because they stay
away from arcanist yeah that's I mean
maybe that's just a Puerto Rican or like
Hispanic thing but generally speaking
when the lights are off your that's
where they dwell so I guarantee yeah
we're right so I'll continue I don't
know they knew the between the differ
between night in life it go outside near
one it's the clown or whatever oh my god
Omar wants to show bad like they like
well go watch it I like it in no I need
this around anticipate everything else
is gonna be dark
I don't like a glare on my TV so he says
right before he reached my bed I woke up
screaming I had another dream a few
nights later where I was in a library
and a girl came up to me and said you've
seen dear David haven't you so I was
like who and she said dear David you saw
him
she continued he's dead he only appears
at midnight and you can ask him two
questions and you said dear David first
then she added but never try to ask him
the third question or he'll kill you it
always comes like this
good story good movie plot yeah then
David came back in another dream same
situation I was in my bed and he was
sitting in the rocking chair near the
window staring at me in the dream I say
dear David how did you die he mumbled an
accident in the store this will stop
asking stupid questions yes am I going
to be a millionaire or what you're not a
fortune-teller so what kind of questions
was that David I don't know I don't know
what that is but oh dear David where did
you means come from near the child
I need guides we had like six doesn't it
ghosts you should know everything so
I'll continue I say dear David what
happened in the sword he groans a shelf
was pushed on my head I'm frozen with
fear I asked who pushed the Shelf that's
three questions yep David doesn't answer
I realize what are you gonna say dear
David those it's not Simon Says yeah I
realized that I've asked the third
question which I'm not supposed to do at
that point
I wake up absolutely terrified the next
couple of days
I googled deaths in the city but can't
find anything about a kid named David
dying in a store
I even tried different names Daniel
Dylan Devon nothing a few weeks go by
without infinite started randomly the
apartment above mine is vacated and I
have the opportunity to move into it
it's a larger apartment so I'm thrilled
another month or two goes by and I sort
of forget about dear David I think you
lost Chuck with me because I moved
upstairs but lately is something strange
is happening for the past four nights my
tests gather at the front door at
exactly midnight and just stare at it
almost like something is on the other
side no no and I can't have cats that's
recognized evil oh yeah I don't know
about that yeah okay that's his front
door dog who would never do that dogs
obviously some miles outside of Utah to
avoid ski and then he says last night I
got a weird feeling and looked out to
people and I'm dead certain I saw
movement on the other side when I open
the door and turn the apartment complex
I feel real mmm airy nothing was there
but my cat seemed unnerved bushy-tailed
etc hmm and that's where I am right now
dear David found me I think I don't know
what to do I'll keep you updated you've
got to lay off that
you don't die he says update for the
sixth night in a row my cat has walked
over to the door promptly at midnight
and stared at it and there's a clock at
midnight so [ __ ] that really girls Rick
[ __ ] yeah I'm pretty mad not to know
but this just screams the fake to me
oh that's just the thought of it being
real so I had a cat - it lives with my
mom now but um I [ __ ] hated when they
did this [ __ ] and it was freaking me the
[ __ ] up so the cat would jump on the bed
and it just kicked it right and like you
don't you can just kind of ignore
because the cat's not doing much lays
down and then I don't know where the cat
goes I need just leave the room yeah
like what the [ __ ]
so I have to leave the room now [ __ ] cat
is rat or termite or something yeah they
can hear the rats in the walls and yeah
[ __ ] them they're evil and they see evil
no I'm on to you [ __ ] [ __ ] no no I
don't think they're evil they're not the
best that's why you want dogs animals
are going to be things that we can't see
how come that's not fair they're able to
sense different things like for example
when there's like an earthquake coming I
remember watching this was an animal
clinic dogs do - yeah they'll start
barking and freaking out like 30 seconds
we need to get the book out of here dude
why are we here staring all the older
rumbles from further away than we can
because their senses are just so
heightened and so when I figured that
out I was like oh so many continues so I
took a photo through the peephole
because I'm too scared to open the door
I feel like I saw something I couldn't
tell so I mustered the courage to open
the door nothing was out there but I
took another photo look at this I don't
see jack [ __ ] he says is it just me or
there's something in the first photo
right where the banister meets the
shelves hiding on the stairs we're
talking about this there's like some
stuff there I don't see anything here oh
I guess I kind of see it
I like he's saying like right there yeah
something right there yeah nice lad oh
he was like I wasn't sure if it was a
smudge or something so I took a second
photo from inside there was something
out there he's talking about like what
kind of couch we used to get it so clear
yeah if you put your iPhone it'll pick
it right up because it's like the size
of a people yeah he also posted a video
whose cat or one cat if you put music to
it it's fake it's just like nailing a
lot just going up to the door you saying
that this happens every single night
like clockwork at exactly midnight
Ruth both his cats she goes to the front
door and the days of sleep are over here
this is a CI [ __ ]
I wonder if David follows the daylight
savings now that he continues I'd bolted
the lock and got in bed because I didn't
know what else to do I can still hear my
cat meowing at the door I'm pretty
scared and I'm supposed to get rid of
your chance look at the cats are my the
cat is still at the door that entire
time yeah and then he says so this all
happened a few days ago and so the story
still developing
because he says good morning I thought I
Cara fie a couple things for new
followers first of all I am Alive
secondly I tested the apartment for
carbon monoxide so I'm not slowly being
poisoned last I have a book coming out
next year but it has nothing to do with
David
this isn't viral marketing it's just a
book of funny comics so I hope that
clears things up I'll keep you all
updated should more weird stuff occur so
he he does right that's a good story I
like it
what is the convict is all about dear
David and this is all just a plot to
thicken it and properties drawn I would
totally does a good story I got I was
like tell me more tell me more tell me
more
yeah me there was an LPS of course I
mean he doesn't die or anything on it
but well nothing you're going to die but
it's like I want my real proof you know
not like a smudge of people or a clock
like you can just change the time I know
that's what I was for the fact that he
had sleep paralysis is like dude you're
just looking at your dream like what
about the girl he said a random girl
approached him no this isn't another
dream oh I thought really just came up
to him like at a library it was like
that was a dream in the library okay
thought it was real life I thought it
was real life - I go back to the girl
like how'd you know that I guess I would
have done it but the genius guy Jim pay
attention you Center in the dream I hope
you guys enjoy this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Music]